foreign
Maggie is calling hi Maggie how are you
hi good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world
well Dave I'd like to liquidate my
portfolio and uh be able to put it I
want to trade on with crypto currency
and I just want your opinion do you
listen to this show
yes I do
okay what are you currently invested in
I I have uh an investment account I have
tsfa and I have a roof account and what
has caused you to go hey you know what
I'm going to trade all of that to go
into crypto
because I'm losing in my portfolio
drastically this year and
um I just know that I don't believe I'm
going to come back like for a long time
like I mean they say it'll come back but
I think it's not going to come back for
10 years and I'm already 72. so I just
feel like
um and I've also have experienced
um like it's not like I haven't I have
been doing crypto trading now for a for
a while have you seen the crypto Market
it's a lot darker than the stock market
you're trading a paper cut for a stab
well I've made money in the crypto
Market how much
uh probably about ten thousand dollars
is that enough to retire on
no what's in your Investments currently
but but I've also picked um
um contracts that have been low like
lower definitely because I haven't had
money that much money to do anything
with
at your age I'm not going to go to Vegas
and just put it all on black and hope
for the best that's not a great
retirement plan
that worries me
okay
um let's back up let's pack up a second
okay
you are you're scared
because your good Investments went down
and yeah right about the time I get
desperate and scared is the step before
I get really stupid
desperate people
and highly greedy people make the worst
Financial mistakes
and your fear is making you do
statistically or suggesting that you do
statistically the equivalent of putting
this money on a roulette wheel or a hand
of Poker
because crypto is extremely volatile
extremely risky at least 100 times more
risky than your current retirement
portfolio
at least
and you're telling me Oh I put money in
the slot machine and I came out with
more money than I put in
uh yeah I'm not doing it I'm not doing
it myself I have a Trader that's helping
me you know like like uh so I never
close my market in a negative position
it's always in a positive position
in crypto correct well Maggie you do
what you want I'm 62.
um yeah I my net worth is hundreds of
millions of dollars and I have precisely
zero in crypto
right and I'm not desperate and I'm not
scared Warren Buffett said and you have
it you know the idea that you have a
Trader doing it for you scares me for
you even more because this is giving you
false confidence hey you've had some
wins
B you have someone whispering in your
ear how wonderful they are and how they
are going to take care of you which is
how people that are 72 years old lose
everything they own
this is how it happens
okay please don't do this
but I don't think that the decision is
really up in the air I think you've
already made your decision
and if I told Maggie hey two years from
now your money's gonna be back to where
it was in your retirement account I
don't know that she would do it but it's
hard to see that far out ahead when you
just see your accounts bleeding out and
so you just want to do anything to not
be doing that one of the wealthiest men
in the world says be greedy when others
are cautious and cautious when others
are greedy
and that's Warren Buffett
and he doesn't mean greedy like being a
uh a bad person a lack of character
greedy he means be aggressive when
others are cautious and cautious when
others are aggressive and crypto is no
place to play
with money that you can't afford to lose
and you're going to lose it
and then you're gonna call me back and
say well I'm gonna have this guy who
made me you know and he's singing a
siren song and I sure hope you don't do
it honey I sure hope you don't do it uh
it sounds like this traitor is probably
telling her oh I'm just liquidating give
me all your money this traitor is
definitely he's talked to her up big
time he's buttered her bread
and this guy's a freaking con artist
he's a crypto con man well we've also
have the quote from Warren Buffett
saying he wouldn't pay 25 for all of the
Bitcoin in the world no and I think he's
got more money than me you and your
Trader put together
so um you know and I don't disagree with
that at all so it's just an extremely
volatile market and that's being kind
it's crazy crazy is what it is but um I
don't have any money in it and there's a
reason crypto is way more down well how
much is it down George do you know I
mean there was it depends on what coin
and a lot of them went bankrupted fraud
they're scams 97 oh and by the way too
Maggie the number it the number of
people that have the number of dollars
lost not in Bitcoin or not in crypto but
in fraud associated with crypto is what
I mean bill in the billions billions two
and a half billion dollars at this point
have been lost to Chris and let me tell
you who the number one target of the
type of Fraud and con is people over 65.
and people that are desperate and scared
empty promises and so
I'm not saying your Trader is a con
artist I'm just saying there's a higher
probability that he's a con artist than
if he was in any other business
because of the number of crypto con
artists that are out there people that
are this this thing is drawn the worst
of the worst and so you can do what you
want to do but you made the mistake of
calling here and asking and we will give
you our opinion and we are experts on
our opinion